taking on 10 new members all at once was
one of the European Union's most
ambitious projects most of the newcomers
were former communist bloc States it
took years of tough negotiations to
convince that he use existing 15 member
states to back the massive enlargement
securing approval was the job of
enlargement Commissioner gun to their
Hogan from Germany not unfollowed balls
back in 2001 the Swedish foreign
minister said to me you're crazy it's
impossible it can be done come with us
come on his mom but the EU proved it was
possible and ten years on most would
agree the process has been a success the
Baltic States Poland and Slovakia have
all become stable democracies with
economic growth rates that are the envy
of the e use older members the new EU
countries have been at the forefront of
developing innovative industries
European Commission vice-president seem
callous remembers the negotiations to
join the EU from his time as Estonian
Prime Minister it has always been clear
that to be is a member of such a bigger
bigger communities are being two
elements one is never alone never 1930s
again and second is economic prosperity
and today of course clear is clear that
the security element the beasts element
this is has a paramount importance today
most Estonians are staunch supporters of
the EU but not all of the blocks new
member states have benefited as much as
cysts onia over the past decade
Hungarian politicians have blamed
Brussels for their country's economic
woes but chaos disputes that
your destiny is in your own hands this
is must be very clear especially for me
coming from a new very small state and
nobody cares nobody cares you are so
small you must do your main decisions
yourself the gap in living standards
between old and new member states remain
significant the euphoria of ten years
ago may have faded and given way to
concern over everyday issues but very
few seriously doubt that the decision to
enlarge the EU was the right one